All right, let's look at some more
stuff. So, the keynote viewer will have
noticed we also have some Lord of the
Rings stuff up here. We of course on the
wall here have Andreal, which is Aragon,
Sword, Flame of the West, the Reforged
by the Broken Shards of Nasil and
Riendell. Because we also set up here to
play War of the Ring Designers Edition,
which is this big, beautiful book by the
way. Here in the middle, we got the Aang
Dice Tower, which is super cool. So,
shout out to Rafos Labing Italy. He even
gave me this map of Middle Earth on wood
for free. We kind of thought that it
would be cool to have the mountains in
water painted a little more red because
it's more evil, but now that I say it
out loud, it actually doesn't make any
sense. With this table, I actually had
to be a bit creative because it needed
to be tall enough to go over the
radiator. And it also need to be like a
square. So, you know what? We just like
bought four coffee tables. That's pretty
much what we did. We also have a wine
fridge up here, but we don't really
drink alcohol, so it's basically just
for soft drinks. And if you're curious,
here's my board game shelfy. As I've
gotten older, I kind of reduce the
amount of games I have. And then the few
games I enjoy playing, I just like buy
everything, all the Etsy stuff. So most
of these games, you could say, are my
favorite games. And then we have some
random stuff here, like this Eclipse
game. I have no idea what it is. It
basically just had the right color
scheme and size to go under Concordia up
here, but I've never tried it. So we got
a corner here with like a little bit of
a pirate theme going on. So we have a
big treasure chest up here, which is the
small west designers edition. Then we
got Raiders of the North Sea with some
expansions. And I kind of regret not
bringing this to the table more often
because it's a really cool game. We just
don't find the time. Dude Imperium is
one of my other favorite games. And
these minis we actually did paint
ourselves. And after we painted these,
we kind of got tired of it because we
have no technique. We have no idea how
to do the shadows and grounding and
stuff. So, we spend way too much time on
this. Arnova is one of my other favorite
games. So, we got a big polar bear here.
That's literally its only job is to like
look at this stupid little polar bear
tile here. That's all it does. The 3D
kiosks and pavilions here are really
cool. Especially this little break token
here. So amazing. And also the iron
money I found on Etsy here is literally
the most beautiful money I've ever seen.
And on the bottom right is probably the
proof that I'm like 10% autist or
something. I mean, who would do
something like that? We're also rocking
some Takenoga Designer Edition over here
with the giant panda. And I'm telling
you, every girl goes crazy about this
game because everything is just so pink
and wonderful, purple. You know,
everybody likes us as well. It's just a
very cute game. I also would like to
point out that the Raven up here is
actually overlooking the Wingspan games
because the Raven is the strongest
Berlin Wingspan. And shout out to my
fellow Dane Assens who made this game
living forest. It's kind of funny
because his name is AS which means ash
when it's literally a game about
preventing forest fire. So that's a
little bit funny. I also enjoy these
games golem edition. And I would like to
point out that it was really really hard
to find the little crystals in exactly
the same colors as the crystals in the
game. Recently we actually put away
terrifying mask to make space for this
giant hero magic the board game room.
So, we got a ton of playmats, a ton of
trees, and these plastic stars here for
the tiles are actually really cool. I
like these a lot. It just makes it more
solid. Makes it look better. So, I
actually attempted to divide the four
corners of the board into some of the
different factions of the game. So, for
example, we got some snow theme going on
here. So, that's tower, of course. The
only thing missing here is that I of
course should have painted all of these
minis. I just suck at painting. It takes
so long, so I couldn't be bothered. But
luckily, I am a bit of a pocket warrior,
so I attempted to make it cool in other
ways. So here we got an archangel from
the castle faction absolutely owning
this sea snake from the cove faction
upgraded into a haspit of course. Here
is like a representation of what would
happen if a gold dragon goes up against
the griffin. Look the griffin is going
to get omega
old. And finally we have the black
dragon from the dungeon faction
overlooking the battlefield. Here we got
some iron money here that I actually
stole from the small world game. And
also this just arrived. It's literally a
dwarf in treasury where you can go and
battle between 50 to 150 dwarfs in order
to get gold and crystal. Here's the turn
marker or the battlefield initiative
marker. We got a bunch of card holders
for the different types of cards in the
game. Here's the funny thing. After I
made this whole thing and we actually
tried it out with some friends, we kind
of realized this table is just too big
for
heroes. It's probably better to have on
a smaller table. So, basically this was
kind of a huge failure, but um at least
it looks cool.
Yeah, good.
deficiency. Stop them.